Next nine/06,
the European Parliament is playing with the subjects
extremely concrete.
Brussels decide.
You are suffering from electricity prices,
energy prices,
increasing your bills.
This is Brussels.
Agriculture
which is now threatened by
free trade agreements,
by standards
always more painful for our farmers
and for our food.
It's Brussels
the pact for migration
who is supported by Emmanuel Macron,
which aims precisely
to relocate migrants entering Europe
in cities and villages
French in a mandatory manner.
It is decided,
in Brussels,
we have ectoplasmic ministers who are there simply
for uh.
Obey Gabriel Attal who himself and the clown
uh of Emmanuel Macron who himself
is the prefect of Mrs.
Vander-layen.
The truth is that,
is that we have a government without power
and so we got uh.
Appointed extras.
But leave me there,
Emmanuel Macron has been at the Élysée Palace for 7 years.
Uh.
When you look at the results of the
security or insecurity,
it's more like 63% more home on uh.
Over 7 years,
the figures of last year's delinquency
are cataclysed.
It simply blends in.
Look what is happening in Mayotte,
I believe that Mr. Darmanin,
he was defended.
I said, I fixed everything.
Well no,
it's not settled in Mayotte.
Gérald Darmanin says something,
he says,
Land law is attractive to immigration.
So we answer him,
if land law is attractive to immigration
in Mayotte,
it is just as much.
Uh. Besides, uh.
In France.
So let's stop with the right of the ground,
that's what we are wearing with Marine Le Pen.
The problem is that the only heavyweights are
heavyweights who missed everything.
Uh.
Darmanin and Dupont,
Moretti, uh.
We can see how it looks in terms of insecurity
and immigration.
Mr. Mayor,
this is crazy inflation,
Second rising price of electricity.
I say to the French,
you have put
Emmanuel Macron in the minority in the assembly
in the last legislative elections,
the same must be done with Macron's Europe.